did you not have a self-preservation
instinct which is I am destroying my
career here again I just thought who
would disagree with this the Father Ted
musical has been cancelled because of
because of them this would have sold out
immed whoever puts this out is basically
printing money the other day the other
day I had to hide my car in case it's
repossessed that's how how bad I my
money situation is at the moment again
what have I said that is so terrible to
deserve that kind of treatment as
someone puts it the patriarchy in
stilettos Graham linan hello what a
journey it's been for you I mean you're
back on the show of course but First
Time In the Flesh it's been years of
what must feel like an arduous Battle
For You expressing your concerns about
trans ideology uh losing a hell of a lot
of opportunities some would say your
career to a large extent and here you
are probably feeling certainly in terms
of what you were saying quite
Vindicated yeah well you you'd kind of
have to tell me I don't I always think
every every shocking news story I hear
about you know rapists in women's
prisons or or men in women's sports I
always used to think oh this is the one
this is the one that will show people
that it's that it's uh it's like when
when Martina Nava broke cover and
started um uh talking about fairness and
sports I thought oh it's over it's over
she's she's like a lesbian icon on so um
and and of course they just monstered
her exactly the same way that they
monstered every everybody who who goes
into this uh uh debate so yeah I you'd
really have to tell me whether it's
turning around or not but if it is I'm
very happy to hear it you know do do you
don't think it's turning around I'm not
sure I because I'm in such a weird
position I'm right at the center of it I
didn't mean to be but the more I
insisted hey this is something that we
we should all be talking about it's it's
not um uh it it's the things they're
telling us are taboos are not really
taboos um the more I said that the more
I kind of increased my
notoriety uh as I say in the book like
pink news have written 75 hit pieces
about me and so there was a kind of a
there's been a swirl of um
misinformation around me also that
extends to my Wikipedia page which we
can't change you know everything is is
written so that it's uh the worst most
negative uh uh view of me and um yeah
I've just been in this strange position
very
isolated uh I wrote the book um what's
it called tell everybody sorry I've
written book you've written the book yes
I've written a book the book is called
tough crowd and it's a memoir the LA the
the the trans stuff is only the last you
know third of the book but
like I've been basically writing that
book while completely
isolated having lost all my contacts
really from my previous life uh during
CO as well so it was like uh two years
of um of being cancelled during Co is a
very strange experience even more
isolating and um yeah all I've been
doing is I've been saying exactly the
same thing that I've been saying for the
last five years um but I had to write a
book before people started actually
listening to the content of what I was
saying one of the things I found
genuinely really striking and unpleasant
about what the the way that people were
treating you is there were some people
who I would have thought owed some
loyalty and this is what happened with
JK Rowling as well where the actors who
got massive breaks from acting in Harry
Potter then essentially stabbed her on
the back or suddenly turned their backs
on her likewise with you you there are
people who got big breaks uh with roles
in things that you'd written uh people
like Graham Norton for example coming
out and saying there's no such thing as
cancel culture having watched you be
canceled for like several years in a row
uh there's only accountability culture I
mean that's got to be
gutting yeah and it keeps happening and
not only that but you people go out of
their way to attack me Bill Bailey said
it was who I cast in in uh Black Books
uh said that my activism was baffling
you know as if it was like just a kind
of um uh you know uh a thing I was doing
for
recreation um you know the issues here
are extremely high uh Stakes you know
the health of children the safeguarding
of women fairness in women's sports
these are all EXT so the idea that it's
baffling and then gra Norton as you say
says there's no such thing as Council
culture he must know that I've had my
life destroyed by trans rights activists
he must know that um the Father Ted
musical has been cancelled because of
because of them and yet he he he you
know he he makes this uh statement about
accountability but again what am I being
held account accountable for you know
everyone agrees with me you know what I
mean it's just that for some weird
reason um this ideology has kind of
taken over in certain areas uh uh
publishing uh the theater uh journalism
um for some reason it's these middle
class P persuits is the wrong word but
it's these middle class uh uh industries
that have been you know um captured MH
and uh everyone outside of these
industries know No One Believes it no
everyone believes that women should have
Fair sports that men shouldn't be um
able to go into women's toilets or
changing areas or Rape Crisis centers
whatever it happens to be simply because
they identify as a Woman No One Believes
this outside of these industries um and
also you cannot speak to anyone about it
if you talk to people about it they do
the equivalent to putting their hands
over their ears and I think it's because
I think it's because because it's a
middle class
phenomenon uh you know everybody in the
middle class knows somebody whose child
identifies as non-binary or uh or or you
know Sim or has a some sort of similar
identification thing going on and these
kids are kind of um feeding their
parents a line of nonsense you know that
the parents you know who love their kids
uh are just swallowing whole so gr when
I was growing up I used to watch Father
Ted love loved it one of my all-time
favorite sitcoms brilliant so many of
you of your shows I watched and I loved
how did you get involved in going from
that to this well I kind of always had
my ear to the ground in terms of things
that were coming down the pipe um when I
was uh when I was just starting out in
comedy I went to see a comedy Master
Class by Danny Simon who was near
Simon's brother and uh I remember at
time someone said a funny thing they
said um cuz he was listed on the ad as
being one of the greatest comedy writers
in the in the world and a friend said
he's not even the greatest in his own
family but this was kind of unfair
because he actually did know his onions
he worked on the Mary Tyler M show he
worked on um uh Bilco which is one of my
favorites um much better known over here
than it is in the US even though it's
American sitcom so I wanted to hear what
he had to say and one of the things he
said was because anyone who's writing
sitcoms should be uh aware of changing
social trends because a very good place
to set a sitcom is at the edge of
something like that something something
new coming along and his example was the
Mary Tyler Mo show because there were
greater number of women entering the
workplace suddenly because of the pill
and uh so they wrote this show about a
woman career woman who comes and works
on a uh a a news program you know except
he used the word women's libers which
was really funny but uh but I always
felt that that was really good advice so
I always kept my antenna up for things
that were changing and it also kind of
naturally aligned with my uh I I'm I'm
just a very curious person I like I like
new music I like new books I I don't
read the classics as much as I read
stuff that's supposed to be very good
now um and yeah I do a couple of things
like the the only reason I'm I'm I'm a
poker player is because I was just an
early adopter of the kind of um the
poker boom that happened when uh Chris
Moneymaker won the World Series um
because he he entered into a competition
for 10 quid or something or free it was
a free ticket span it up into a series
of tournament entries kept winning and
then won the World Series so it just
completely uh created a poker boom and I
remember getting into poker thinking oh
was very special very special really no
one else is doing this everyone else was
doing it it was just because I was kind
of always on the lookout for new things
I could get involved with um and in the
same way I kind of uh realized that the
there was a big thing happening with the
internet uh which was that some people
knew exactly what it was and exactly
what was going on and other people
hadn't a clue like they didn't know the
words for things they didn't know that
you know I don't know I'm trying to
think what's a good example uh well you
know you like God this is one from the
book but but like um you could say to
someone what browser are you using and
someone won't have a clue what you're
talking about yeah so I realized that
was a good uh someone who knows a lot
about computers someone who doesn't know
a lot about computers is a good
conversation that will uh Mark that new
social change you know
so the IT Crowd kind of got born out of
that so then I was still paying
attention I was still trying to see what
was coming down the pipe and uh it was
actually an episode of The IT Crowd I
wrote uh that had a trans character in
it and I noticed that the the push back
was extraordinarily
vicious uh much more so than any other
joke I'd written that had got got a kind
of any kind of push back in fact I'd
never really got any push back for a
joke before this was the first time
which marked out as oh this is
interesting and bear in mind you were
joking about Catholic priests in Ireland
in the '90s yes yeah exactly but then
again it would I I don't want to give
myself too much credit there it was kind
of safe Catholic priests don't try and
destroy your career you know but like um
but uh I noticed that happening first of
all and then uh gamergate came along and
on gamergate I was sure I had completely
um
uh I completely absorbed what the issue
was what was going on and I dismissed it
as to everyone who would listen to me
and I had a lot of followers as a
misogynistic hate Campaign which on some
levels it was there were people kind of
um tagging along with it for that reason
but there were also a lot of guys who
thought that they were fighting uh uh uh
corruption in gaming journalism you know
and I just kind of became a node one
more node of people who are saying it's
just a misogynistic hate campaign that's
all it is like a thought terminating
cliche just to shut it down rather than
looking at all the complexities see what
was going on see if there were any valid
uh arguments from the other side none of
that no strong Manning a case just I
just had my weapon which was it's just a
misogynistic hate campaign so anyway
gamerg passed and then I started
noticing that suddenly the
during gamergate one of the one of the
most um famous things that happened was
a thing called operation lollipop where
all these trolls set up fake accounts of
black women and uh pretended that they
found uh Father's Day
offensive right and they set up a
hashtag called something like end
Father's Day yeah right it was designed
just to create as much Havoc as they
possibly could I remember at the time
you know the people who I was was uh
allying myself with on the left very
much on the left I was always a very
good little Lefty MH um but these people
were you know very critical of this um
of this uh this piece of trolling men
dressing as men pretending to be women
online to create Havoc was considered by
the left a bad thing when the right did
it and then the left started doing it
the same I just saw the same types of
anime
uh avatars popping up that were on the
other side during during gamergate and I
realized that you know basically there's
always a huge contingent of men on the
internet who really don't like women
they despise women and they will do
anything they can to undermine them and
troll them and get their own back for
all sorts of real and imagined slights
in their in their past you know and they
just switched horses yeah I'm not saying
they're exactly the same people was
definitely a crossover you know and they
just started abusing women online
targeting their work doing all the
gamergate tactics you know which
included swatting you know what swatting
is SWAT swatting is when uh do well do
you want to well I it's very simple so
in a for example if um people are
watching somebody who plays computer
games on Twitch they will find out what
their address is and then they will
report a very serious crime as allegedly
happening in that
so that they so that they can watch on
camera as a SWAT team descends on this
person that they're watching like like
the camera is just an added bonus in
that in that particular uh case it was
done to a lot of women during game of
gate apparently you know and apparently
one of the things that SWAT teams do
when they go into a situation is they
immediately kill the pet they kill the
family pet so even if the even if it
doesn't result in the death of their
targets they've still caused a lot of
distress and all this sort of stuff
anyway again this was a tactic terrible
worst thing in the world uh when it
happens on the um on the right but when
it happened when the left were doing it
as happened to Tim uh what's his name p
Tim P Tim P lately there's not a there's
not a a word about it you know so I saw
these kind of Internet War tactics being
used against the latest Target which was
left-wing women who were being called
Turfs
who were uh being subjected to work
tribunals um uh they were being reported
to the police uh all sorts of things
were going on and I just thought I had
what I thought was a natural thought
which was this is not right this is a
bad thing we should all be trying to
stop this but again because these new
these this new Target were W were
left-wing
women well actually no I'm kind of
confusing the issue because what's very
interesting about this sorry excuse me
let me rewind a little
bit this new Target with the the the
women who are being the women in
gamergate who are being targeted were
Gamers right and gaming journalists and
and and whatever um the women who were
being targeted this time were left-wing
uh were leftwing women who are B who are
really the backbone of a lot of leftwing
activism in the in the UK you know like
uh two of the people who were targeted
were Helen steel who is the woman who
single-handedly sued McDonald's you know
whatever you think of the the action it
was an incredible feat for her to do it
and she was hugely respected uh among
the left for and Linda Bellos who came
up with I think Black History Month in
the in in the UK you know these are two
significant figures in leftwing activism
they're being called bigots
Linda Bellis is black and they're being
called bigots and it's like again well
this isn't right why is this why is this
happen I should I should say something
you know but again all these tactics men
pretending to be women online targeting
jobs targeting
livelihoods when gamergate was doing it
when when when the right were doing it
it was the worst thing in the world and
it was a sign that Trump and everything
is going to be create a hell on Earth
for uh LGBT people and all the rest of
it and feminists and women's and women's
women women's women's yeah um but then
when the left started doing it exact
same tactics men pretending to be women
online targeting livelihoods targeting
uh uh you know one of the things that
happened to me when I came out was
people would literally just kind of
contact all my friends and say can I
just ask why you're still following gra
Lin you know and it was just like a kind
of a everything was done except talk
about the issue the issue
itself you could you couldn't you
couldn't bring it you couldn't talk talk
about it because yeah S I was going to
say and when was the moment you came out
when was the moment you stepped forward
and went enough's enough I'm going to
make my just to be clear he's not gay he
just said what he thinks yeah of course
cuz you can't be gay cuz gay means there
a binary so we can't have it well
apparently a lot of I heard one guy
tweeted recently that gay men are more
frightened of saying their GC than they
are of coming out than they were of
coming out but well again sorry sorry to
bring up another bit in the book but I
guess it is kind of you know Central but
I was on morphine I I just I've had an
operation uh to get a testicle removed
uh like Hitler um and uh and uh I was on
morphine and there was a wound on my
side that was covered by a bandage yeah
uh and I thought doesn't feel too bad at
all I hopped hopped to my feet choked on
my jeans and just got ready to go and
the nurse came in and was like what the
[__] what are you doing and I was like
oh sorry I thought it was just a you
know quick it was supposed to be a day
release thing you're supposed to have
the operation and walk out later so
anyway I got back onto the
trolley uh the morphine started you know
was still kicking in I didn't realize it
had that's why I wasn't feeling any pain
um and I just had my phone I dis ously
had my phone and I've been I've been
studying it for a few weeks or months
even I've been going what is this am I
getting anything wrong is there
something I'm missing and was and and I
just couldn't I couldn't locate it you
know they would people would say things
like oh Trans people have always been
around we're just they're just braver
now that's the that's the reason we're
now noticing them it's like what so and
was but but it's like the reason I don't
have bollocks is cuz Shakespeare didn't
notice them and he noticed everything
else about Humanity so how did he miss
an entire cohort of people who have
always existed you know and but you got
involved in this essentially when you're
on morphe yeah right and that's when you
that's when you started tweeting that's
when you started to get involved that's
when you made your voice public but when
you when you obviously got off morphine
which I assume you are gr it was about a
year later
yeah but where did you not have a self
preservation instinct which is I am
destroying my career here this is a
career that I've worked really hard on
this is a career that is incredibly
Stellar I'm universally respected in my
industry which can I just say in comedy
is practically
impossible and then you and then you hit
this particular self-destruct button
well that's the thing I didn't realize
it was a self-destruct button again I
just thought who would disagree with
this women are being swatted women are
being sorry not swatted that was
gamergate women are being uh women are
being targeted they're losing their
livelihoods you know one of the first
stories I heard about in this fight was
um Vancouver rape relief which had a
dead rat nail to the door because it
won't accept men into the space because
it's just for women only and it includes
trans identified men in that they nailed
a dead rat to the door you know and then
there like like there's other stories
that have happened since a Amy ham who
is a Canadian nurse who put up a poster
saying I love JK Rowling she's still in
a work tribunal 3 years later you know
fighting for her job and so I just
thought well clearly we have to help
these people and it never occurred to me
that people would go well actually no
we're not we're not we're not helping
not only are we not helping these women
we're not helping you all these
colleagues I'd worked with for years you
know and so I kind of made a Bad Bet
when I was in my you know morphine State
I bet on on you know loyalty and uh and
I bet that that my friends many of whom
have daughters would want to you know be
in the same fight and were you are you
must have been shocked then when you
know you get people who are friends who
are colleagues some of whom actually got
their big breaks for working on things
that you'd written um people like Graham
Norton coming out later saying well
doesn't having watched you canceled over
years then saying there's no such thing
as cancel culture there's just
accountability culture yeah because he
could just say nothing yeah he could
just say nothing and that would still
you know you can have your opinion about
about that but to pretend that what's
happened hasn't happened and actively
say something to the contrary that is
yeah quite something yeah but but I've
I've found that it is completely
standard for this fight people will do
anything to avoid having this
conversation and gra Norton has just
kind of decided that I've just popped
out of existence and the issue is is
such a nonissue that he won't even
discuss it he you never hear him saying
why women shouldn't have Fair sports or
or Vancouver rape relief should have a
dead rat nail to the door because they
know their their positions are
indefensible so what they do to save
their own skin which is what he's doing
is uh is you know they they gen
every so often and one of the things you
can gen you know one of the ways you can
gen afflect to the to the Mob is by
saying there's no such thing as Council
culture even when your immediate
colleague has had his life destroyed by
it you we'll be back with gram in a
minute but first do you remember the
Canadian trucker protest in 2022 where
thousands of Canadians came out to
protest covid restrictions and vaccine
mandates now these protests lasted for
weeks and the people out on the street
needed funds as any Grassroots protest
would so people set up online
crowdfunding campaigns which raised
millions of dollars incredible but once
the Canadian authorities had started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure to close the
campaigns it didn't take long for the
biggest crowdfunding platform the one
we've all heard of to completely
capitulate and shut the campaigns down
now this is where our partners give send
go come in they step in when the other
platforms backed off and raised millions
of dollars for the truckers when they
were criticized and dragged through the
Canadian courts gifs and go said it
respected diverse views and believed
hope and freedom are values worth
fighting for this is why we're proud to
partner with GI and go so if you need to
crowdfund for whatever means the most to
you then don't go to the big Tech
platforms we recommend you do it on give
send go starting a campaign on give send
go is easy easy and intuitive go to giv
send go.com today that's giv send go.com
to start raising money for whatever is
important to you and now back to the
interview and I wanted to come back to
the question Francis was exploring with
you which
is how can I put this none of us are
short of issues to care about I think
that's fair to say there's modern
slavery there is uh I mean there's Wars
every every [__] country at the
moment you know like there's so many
things that we could all care about but
you really focused in on this issue as
being very important why is this such an
important issue to
you well again first of all I have a
daughter and I I have a mom and a and a
you know and I I I had an I had a wife
you know
um I thought their their rights were
important and I and again I just find it
I think sometimes I find that
conservative spaces still don't realize
how key this is you know this is like
the door that unlocks everything else CR
critical race Theory and everything else
if you can if half the population can
dominate the other half and take big
slices of the pie that over a hundred
years after the suffrage ATS we'd worked
out how to create a little bit of I know
it's a dread word but Equity between men
and women right and suddenly there were
a group of men who were suddenly
grabbing pieces of this pie the best
example is sports you know they have a
massive physical Advantage it's not
reduced by transitioning and many many
don't transition they just say they're
transitioning and they get you know why
wouldn't you do it you get like huge
cash
prizes but again it's like
um it's so clearly wrong it's like it's
like you've kind of suddenly given some
of the worst people in the world a
licensed to behave abominably you know
like is there anyone lower than someone
who would who would join a woman's sport
just to beat it I don't think so you
know so like really gam worse than a
murderer a pedero a rapist sorry yeah
you're right you're right one of my
other problems I used to be a a movie
and film critic I'm sometimes given to
hyperbole there a rhetorical flourish
it's a rhetorical flourish but like I do
think that is pretty low you okay fair
um so I just kind of thought oh well
everyone will see this like I remember
once I got into an argument with John
Ronson the journalist now John
Ronson he's someone who should be all
over this he wrote a book called so
you've been publicly shamed great book
yes justifiably a well uh regarded book
he told a story of uh Justine scko I
think her name was who famously told a a
joke that was deliberately uh uh
interpreted in in the worst possible
light um while she was on a plane flight
going from somewhere to somewhere she
said uh I'm going to Africa hope I don't
get AIDS I actually I won't because I'm
white L yeah it's and by the time she
landed in Africa like her life had been
absolutely destroyed and it was clearly
a anti-racist joke it was about it was
about um Western uh comfort and uh her
life was destroyed and John wrote a very
uh moving interview with
her and I thought well John will be all
over this because this is the this is
the
industrialization of those kinds of
shaming
tactics not a bit of it you know I
showed him a photograph of a huge
hulking BL playing in a in a in a girls
basketball team all the girls are like
in their teens and he seemed more
worried about the bloke's feelings than
any of the girls and why do you think
that is why do you think that this
industry has been captured to such an
extent particularly comedy grahe because
if you think the greatest comedy in my
opinion I'm I'm sure it's probably yours
as well are the ones who point out the
the things that nobody talking about
saying the emperor has no clothes etc
etc a great hulking bloke playing
basketball with a load of 14y olds I
mean that to me seems a pretty ripe you
know pretty ripe territory for yeah like
Eddie I find it what I find really funny
I remember once um what's his name Nish
Kumar did a did a list of people who who
were joking about uh um uh I call him
the Smiths um what's his name uh I call
oh his name Smith Sam Smith yeah I call
him the Smiths cuz he's they then
pronouns and um you know I would make
fun of this because I think it's absurd
yeah uh and he's an absurd figure just
the same way I made fun of I remember
sting cut an incredibly absurd figure uh
when he was famous we used to watch him
on TV and author would always say watch
him take off his shirt he will find a
way you know but now the idea that this
ridiculous man Sam Smith who's demanding
we all use counterintuitive pronouns for
him is somehow off limits Nish Kumar did
a list me and Andrew Doyle were in it
and Nigel farage I think was on it
people who who who are making fun of Sam
Smith you know and it's
like what are you talking about these
are the people we make fun of like Eddie
isard is another ridiculous figure
you know it's like running for running
for election in in a Pink Beret using
women's toilets and just no one's
allowed to say this is a little bit
wrong this is not right he shouldn't be
doing it you know and no one no one's
able to to to be comic about it you know
so that was one of the things I tried to
do when I was in this I tried to make
people realize we have this YouTube
channel called the mess we're in uh
where I talk about these issues with um
a Canadian gay man named ardy Morty and
a uh Welsh feminist Helen stanland and
they're really smart and they're really
funny and we have a great laugh on it
and that was important to me to break
break the spell you know it's like Nish
Kumar is saying we can't make fun of of
ridiculous people you know and it's and
and it's true it's like the whole thing
is like a disease in comedy like when
when did Trevor Noah ever go viral I
don't think ever when did when is Nish
what's are what are Nish Kumar's five
best jokes you know and they're just
it's just they've they've changed their
role into kind of I call them regime
comedians they're just mouthpieces for
what the mob is currently into you know
and but grae I agree with all of what
you said in theend but why why do you
think let's really try and explore the
core of this why is it that comedy which
is meant to be all of these things we've
spoken about has been taken over by this
ideology what is it about it is it the
people in the industry is it the
comedians themselves what's going on I
think one of the things before you
answer grah we should say is it's the
British comedy scene this has not been
the case in America in anything like the
same way yes in America people have no
problem making fun of this issue really
on TV may be a different issue but you
go in the comedy I mean you go to
Rogan's club for example there's no
shortage of people and and this isn't
just in the last year or so like there
have been lots and lots of people been
able to make jokes about all all of
these issues I think there's something
uniquely special about the British
industry absolutely but it may not be
the reason it was C captured well I'm
not sure maybe you'll be able to tell me
whether the the the makeup is different
of of you know American comedians but I
think comedy is a middle class another
middle class industry and it's and
basically this is a a mass delusion that
has particularly affected the middle
class you know you don't you don't often
look at comedy as a way to you know
break into millions or to to have a
career if you're working class I don't
think it comes the the thought doesn't
come as naturally but a bunch of middle
class people sitting around uh nothing
else to worry about except taking the ab
out of things with their friends of
course comedy occurs to you know so they
get into comedy and then suddenly you
know you just got a kind of a a middle
class ring I guess of and that
unfortunately it seems to have only
happened recently that there is
acceptable and unacceptable subjects you
know like and even even when you don't
cover them I I I I was banned from the
aded
festival my ACT it's just silly jokes
it's just like it CRA jokes or or Father
Ted jokes there very I think don't think
there's anything about the trans issue
maybe one joke once but it's like you
know it suddenly there's a there's
certain people who no no they're not
allowed they're not allowed to be on a
stage or in front of an audience or
speak to people no no no no no you know
like where where did that come from I
think that might be one of the reasons
actually because the one thing that they
do have in the US is different scenes in
different places and so you might not be
welcome on the you know Los Angeles
scene if you make those jokes but you
can go to Austin you can go to New York
you can go to different parts of the
country whereas in the UK there's one
scene sure it's controlled by about
three people and if those three people
happen to think you know trans women or
women or whatever and you don't that's
sort of you yeah isn't it that seems to
me a big part of it as well is like
there's one narrative I mean Andrew
Doyle who is a mutual friend of ours of
course uh always makes this point about
na Burns in 2018 this is the the woman
who runs the Edinburgh Comedy Festival
said you know I look forward to the the
woke future of Comedy where comedians
decide what isn't isn't
acceptable and if that's one person and
there's three others who happen to you
know be TV Commissioners and whatever
sort of between the four of them they
can basically set the agenda yeah and
then every and then they don't even have
to enforce it because everyone else is
going to fall in line yeah and also
there you know the the thing that
happened to me is was was you know as a
warning for the others you know it's
like it's like you're the head on Spike
yeah yeah and so you know everybody is
being frightened out of engaging in this
conversation and one of the things that
I've been desperately trying to get
across with people for the last five or
six years is if we all do it they can't
win you know have you ever heard of the
oh God this this may end this may end up
on The Cutting Room floor maybe just
keep this for your patreon people um
have you ever heard of a game called
werewolf no werewolf is a party game we
used to play with all my celebrity mates
you know about 12 of us around the table
you need a lot of people you know uh
everyone gets a piece of paper it's
either got uh villager written on it
vast majority but two have the word
werewolf written on it it's divided into
day and night phases someone runs the
game to make sure no one's cheating and
they go okay it's night time everyone
close your eyes everyone closes their
eyes then they go werewolves open your
eyes the two werewolves open their eyes
and they see the other one and they give
a little thumbs up to show that they've
they've clocked each other and then the
woman says werewolves choose someone to
kill during the night and the werewolves
go
that right they say okay everyone close
your eyes it's morning time open them
again during the night Francis was
killed MH the game then
predictable you always get rid of the
badly written character first you'd be
the first to go in any scenario that's
exact no it'd be the it'd be the black
character first then me yeah so like
there's a so basically there's then a
conversation and this is where it gets
interesting during the day phase between
all the uh all the villagers and the two
werewolves over who the werewolves are M
and the two werewolves are trying to
draw attention to other people I heard a
noise from over here and the other
werewolf is like yeah I think I did too
and all that sort of thing uh now the
game then at the end of the day the the
villagers have to decide who they're
going to kill and they say well we're
going to kill Constantin and um it's
revealed by the person running the game
I'm afraid constant was a villager and
the game
continues okay the villagers win the
game if they kill both werewolves the
werewolves win the game if they kill all
but two
villagers the game was invented by a
student of Sociology in Russia who
wanted to prove his thesis that an
uninformed majority will always lose a
battle of information against an
informed minority wow yeah and the
werewolves usually win even if you have
12 people around the table the the
werewolves would usually I once won by
turning in the other werewolf I mean you
you are Show Business greme do you know
what I mean yeah well that's clever you
turned on the other werewolf yeah and we
won wow so that just shows when you have
hidden information yeah you can
completely manipulate a large group of
people that's happening in the NHS it's
happening in publishing it's happening
in every middle class industry because
there's always one or two or three
people who think they themselves are
non-binary have a kid who's told them
they're nonbinary or whatever it happens
to be and those people are controlling
the conversation so when Rachel Rooney
who is a a you know uh who is a
children's author wrote a beautiful book
called um my body is me little book for
toddlers like you might call it an anti-
dysphoria book A book to make you
comfortable in your own bones for little
toddlers they destroyed her career they
they they they called her a they said
she was uh engaging in conversion
therapy they wrote to um now now the
people who did this were in the Society
of
authors the authors Union who are
supposed to stand up for these for their
members and they destroy they destroy
they help destroy her career cuz there's
a couple of werewolves going hold on a
second this is a bit transphobic and
then everyone else is too afraid to say
no it's not CU then you become the
werewolf suspect etc etc etc exactly
that's it it's like we're not going to
leave we're not going to put that for
that that will be in the interview it's
such a good way of looking at it and
I've always saw oh by the way just in
case people are looking for it and think
there's no good it was it was actually
originally called
Mafia yeah I've played that game and
you're the werewolves do usually win
yeah
um it's such an interesting point
because I've always my sense of history
from what I've read and understood is a
small highly motivated minority willing
to off often willing to break the rules
that usually means in the historical
context use violence but you this is a
form of violence it's just not physical
it's destruction in other ways right a
small motivated minority willing to play
by a different set of rules yeah will
often be able to cower the majority
because of the collective action problem
which is what you were talking about um
and and it's played out in various mass
movements before you know uh from
Christianity to to Communism to national
socialism these say Scientology is the
best example where even the people at
the bottom level didn't know some of the
actual uh teachings of Scientology they
were kept in the dark until the very
last moment the best funniest example of
that is when Paul I think it was Paul
haggus who wrote crash a not very good
Oscar winner uh reached the highest
level once and he went in for a meeting
and they said well this is what's going
on
uh A God Called zenu put planes inside
volcanoes and he just suddenly realized
after years of working for the
Scientologist these people are insane
yeah you know and uh I guess there's a
similar thing going on here there's a
kind of a there's a kind of a deliberate
um uh forgive me if I run off this the
question I hope I hope I'm not but you
do whatever you want but there's a
deliberate kind of obfuscation around
key key aspects of this um issue isue
like for instance what does trans mean
does it mean
transexual right that's the way I would
interpret it the way I used to um but
now it appears to mean transexual and
Eddie isard and Eddie is a
crossdresser so hold on what is a
transexual a transexual is someone who's
had an operation to cut off their
genitals you know that's what that's how
I always uh thought of it you know like
I don't know even that definition might
be well even that's not satisfactory
because it's like they didn't like wake
up one day and when oh I feel gender
dysphoria you know there's a process
that will take you up that and and one
thing that's happened is I think that
there's there's a definition of gender
reassignment in the equalities act that
says something like um uh they have had
this uh procedure or are thinking of
having it so that means everybody is
thinking of it anybody going to be
thinking of having it and it re I
realized that like quite early on that
the the this was a a self- selecting
group of people who just said I'm trans
and that could range from edzard right
to someone who has debilitating gender
dysphoria has an obsessive uh uh
recurring invasive thought that they
need to get rid of this to make
themselves uh okay and um
and it's like these two have nothing to
do with each other they have nothing to
do with each other so why are there so
so it seemed to me that suddenly you've
created this informed minority who can
like there's a very famous um sorry this
is probably please do cut out any of
this where I'm rambling
but as to the werewolves Point there's a
very famous um document called the
Denton's document have you heard of it
no it was a law firm called Dentons who
who worked pro bono on advice to give
trans rights activists and it was
literally for this for this reason on on
pushing
through uh laws or or bills or whatever
that would not be popular with the
public and there's a number of bits of
advice given including avoid the media
don't get drawn into
debates uh Target young politicians you
know
and when you think about some of the
people like Nadia Wht Whittingham and
Wham and Mary Black who are pushing this
stuff they're all they're all really
young yeah you know um and very
empathetic and not very bright this is
the optimum combination someone who
really cares but doesn't really
understand the issues very well exactly
exactly and um uh and so the Denton's
document laid all this out in very bald
terms you know and as I always say this
is the first civil rights move
that has been told to avoid the
media and when you think of it when have
you seen figures who are supposedly on
the other side of this issue right like
Susie Green or or the the um Nancy Kelly
late of Stonewall when have you seen
them on panel not panel shows on news
shows discussing this issue they don't
do it because the the um the desire is
to create a completely
suffocating um uh the desire is to
completely suffocate the conversation
yeah to give it no air whatsoever and
grahe on that point about werewolves I
think what has been very instructive to
that issue is the revelation of how
exactly did our civil service become
convinced about all of this how exactly
did The Police become convinced of all
of this how exactly did other government
and sort of quango like structures
become convinced that this ideology is
the right way to go and we now know
don't we yeah yeah all the tactics that
were used in this uh in the Denton's
document and you can download it you can
read it yourself and and there's some
very good pieces about it online but
specifically I mean mermaids Etc being
heavily involved this organization in
essentially teaching them these highly
contested ideas to put it very mildly
well here's an interesting thing uh did
you know that mermaids used to be a
great Organization no I didn't know that
no yeah mermaids in the old days well
like stoneball yeah exactly and mermaids
in the old days were specifically for
children who had dysphoria you know then
Susie Green came along Susie Green had a
gay or at least gender non-conforming
child who the husband he now I'm not
saying anything out of order here this
was a TED Talk that was up for years
until it was suddenly taken down without
explanation and she said that her
husband didn't like the son playing with
girls toys mhm you know and she's doing
it like a TED Talk she's got the thing
she's doing all the hand you know the
hand gestures you get in TED Talks you
know and then was and all the little
phrases which would change my life
forever you
know so and she's doing it right but
there's this huge gap it's like her
husband didn't like him playing with
with girls toys suddenly she goes to
Thailand with the kid at 16 and gets his
penis cut off you know so she told him
he was trans
she put them on hormones put them on
puberty blockers and hormones in fact
there's a there's a very famous excerpt
of a documentary about her where she's
laughing because the her 16-year-old
son's penis wasn't large enough to
create the inverted vagina this is
another reason why people don't like to
talk about this issue because it's
horrible um so this woman went into
mermaid where you know she's obvious
she'd obviously spent too much time into
the night on forums listening to other
people who think they have trans kids
and believing everything they say and
she entered into mermaids and she
changed the culture at mermaids
similarly you know I I used to follow
there was a there was a so social worker
her nam's Lisa M she's amazing um and
she um she said it only takes a few
people to groom an
organization so again and you you know
and they've even made it a kind of a
official part of a business in the
diversity and inclusion or EDI I'm not
sure what it's called in I prefer I
prefer die D yeah yeah deie departments
and do you know what I mean like like
one of the things that made me realize
something was really badly wrong at
hatrick was when I handed in a a a
sitcom called canel and uh they gave
back sensitivity notes and I thought the
whole sitcom is about you know
how this is ridiculous she the
sensitivity reader said people might
think you're making fun of diversity and
inclusion
measures you know and we we so we've
touched on hatrick which are probably
one of the biggest production companies
comedy production companies in the UK
when did it start affecting your career
when did you start noticing colleagues
turning against
you well it didn't really one of the
things cancellation especially during Co
was that it was it all just happened
silently you know you don't really still
I don't there may be some people who
just think I'm great and think I'm
completely on the right track but I
can't call them to be to face another
disappointment you know um and people
you know uh yeah they just didn't
announce well graem L's nonperson now it
just it just kind of happens the thing I
the thing I I but hold on they're
sitting on your musical now Monday yeah
hatrick so you clearly know that they're
not they're not they have the rights to
it they're not going to let you do it
for half the rights and the other half
are owned by me Authur and Neil Hannon
and they're sitting on it in what I
think is an act of kind of preempt of
cultural vandalism simply because I've
stood up for women's rights you know and
I've stood against the medicalization of
children which I would argue is
everyone's should be everyone's priority
you know what I mean so we have the
musical we had it on its feet we we put
it on a few times there were even little
dance routines you know to try and sell
it to uh to uh uh people who might put
money in all this sort of stuff and now
they're just sitting on it it should be
on it should be on it should have been
on for the last two years you know the
other day the other day I had to hide my
car in case it's
repossessed that's how how bad I my
money situation is at the moment you
know I should have a musical on it
should it should be up and running for
like 3 years but because of this
ridiculous and you know homophobic
misogynistic
movement it it was just it was just
stolen and and all hatrick and my
colleagues would have to do would be to
say of course women should have Fair
Sports of course children shouldn't be
mutilated and sterilized do you know
what I mean these are not controversial
positions to hold but for some reason
they refuse to do it
and the thing that's also heartbreaking
yet really says a lot about this case is
the musical is a musical of Father Ted
yeah one of the most beloved sitcoms of
the last 30 odd years which is still
shown which is still quoted which the
the com the character of father dugall
is now a staple when people talk about
comedy and modern comedy this would have
sold out immedi us out is basically
printing money yeah and and and it's but
it's not being stopped because of the
public it's being stopped because
theaters are refusing to put it on and
hatrick and my colleagues are refusing
to defend me and say you know this is
ridiculous and make an issue out of it
even even so your colleagues the people
that you wrote this with yeah yeah like
like I spoke to some of them afterwards
and again I mean it's so weird this is
what I mean when I say when you're at
the center it's hard to know what's
going on because they didn't seem to
understand the issues you bring them up
and it's like it's the first time you've
told them about it and over the years I
they had seen what had been happening to
me they'd seen me lose opportunities
I've been telling them exactly what the
what the problem was been getting
largely agreement you know and suddenly
it's seen again as a kind of a hobby I
have you know they're saying no they're
they're they're they're sterilizing a
generation of gay kids they're telling
gay kids that they're actually straight
but they were born in the wrong body and
they need drugs surgery to take care of
that problem that's evil and I cannot
get anyone to stand by my side and say
yeah you're right that's evil you know
we'll be back with graham in a minute
but first we wanted to tell you about
Factor we've discovered a fantastic way
to stay on track with your nutritional
goals while saving time if you're in
America and you're looking for dietician
approved Chef prepared fresh never
frozen meals to fuel you on jam-pack
days then you need to take a look at
factor factor is America's number one
ready to eat meal delivery service and
they'll help you eat well for breakfast
lunch and dinner with nutritious and
flavorful ready to eat meals delivered
straight to your door leave the calor
counting to their dietitians and leave
the planning prepping and cleanup to
their chefs while you're out there
crushing it factor of making sure each
meal has the nutrition you need and the
flavor you're looking for
choose from over 35 chef-crafted meals
every week that support a healthy
lifestyle and meet your meal preferences
whether it's vegan veggie Protein Plus
or wholesome options there are also
calorie conscious options that don't
skimp on Flavor try delicious dietitian
approved calorie smart meals that are
under 550 calories per serving the food
is fresh and the ingredient quality is
on point for example the meat is from
grass-fed or pasture raised animals and
is free of anti antibiotics hormones and
GMOs it's high quality stuff and you
just have to run a Google search to see
how well Factor comes out in reviews to
try Factor head to factor meals.com
trigger 50 and use code trigger 50 to
get 50% off that's code trigger 50 at
factor meals.com to get 50% off now back
to the interview
and this the the thing that shows in a
way because how weird this all is is I
remember when I was growing up
corporations whether it's TV or we all
kind of accepted that they were immoral
the bottom line was a bottom line and as
long as it was going to make money then
that's fine but they would rather not
make money yeah lots of money
particularly during a pandemic and
coming out of a pandemic where
everybody's short of money
yeah because of this
I wrote it literally thinking that it
will be a bit like being in a lovely
Mass you know yeah like one of the
things I you know like one of the things
I feel even though I'm an atheist I do
feel a little bit of a loss of the fact
that we don't have uh a weekly event
where we all go and shake hands with our
neighbors you know and I thought I kind
of saw this as this great release from
Co was desperate to uh for it to happen
uh uh as soon as Co ended but you know 2
years of having my reputation destroyed
75 hit pieces about me in in pink news
my Wikipedia vandalized and and kind of
Rewritten every time we try and make it
you know halfway neutral it just took
its toll and uh by the time we were
ready to go by the time Co was over they
just said it wasn't going to happen
because of unless I unless I uh wasn't
involved with it you know and the thing
that really got me was I said to them
look okay I'll stay away but I'd like to
come in every so often and see how it's
doing see if it's on the right track and
Jimmy mville of hatrick said no we want
a clean
break you
know again what have I said that is so
terrible to deserve that kind of
treatment you know uh you know what it's
so wrong when you talk about it's just
so it's just wrong and I think what
you're actually being punished for my
sense is you're punished for being first
and you're punished for because you had
a large voice yeah maybe that's what I
think you're being punished for yeah and
you're in the wrong industry if you were
like an oil well rig man or something no
one would give a [__] yeah exactly I
mean like when I came over here like I
never got any um anti-irish racism I got
one weird weird I think someone called
me a patty in a police station once I
think that was it but then again I was
in a police station um but like uh but
like the rest of the time I've had you
know everyone's very respectful and and
everything's been going great but like I
think what I did was in the end was I I
uh transgressed certain uh uh a certain
e etiquette in that like you know this
is a middle class movement it's Bor
middle class kids who are often the
victims of it and you know I was kind of
um breaking an Unwritten rule for going
against little Jimmy's idea that he's
actually a third sex that's never
existed before you know do you think
part of it as well is that you are a
heretic in that you were
you you were firmly part of the liberal
establishment yeah I I was no yeah yeah
that's how I see it and and we've all
got to be so careful about becoming
nodes about just transferring
information that we because one or two
like what was crazy about about the
trans women or women thing is that all
these people who i' believed for years
including people in the gamergate fight
who I'd been fighting for trying to you
know defend them from trolling and all
the sorts of stuff they believed it and
and and it was
like it just kind of made me realize oh
my God what else is [__] do you know
what I mean all these kind of um things
i' taken for granted all these reasons
that I'd gone in with both feet when I
was fighting with someone online and you
know like which was never a problem when
I was when I was doing it against the
right but again do it against left
you're dead um and I was using exact I
was I was actually quite polite during
the conversation because I knew that any
slip would be punished I knew the way
they worked you know but it didn't
matter they used to do things like they
would they took a screenshot of a joke I
made to my wife where I called her a
[__] and used that as an example that I
was a misogynist wow you know they faked
uh they they fake mset comments where I
admit to sending dickpics to women on
mset um you know one one guy a doctor
did a fake prescription for me like that
I needed mental pills and put it on a
real NHS prescription you know
so you know it was just like a sorry
just remind me how we got into this
because sometimes these these things
these things there's so many stories to
this piles piles they pile up and I lose
my train of thought so we were talking
about Heretics oh yeah yeah so uh yeah
but like it was kind of um I think one
of the re reasons why I was landed on
with with hob nail boots so to speak was
because like JK rolling uh I was very
very leftwing I was extreme I I ticked
all the boxes you know Israel tick
everything you know um and then you know
JK Rowling did the same thing and
similar to me as well JK Ro JK ring
again impeccable credentials is a lefty
you know uh but but more than that as
well we had both created things that
they liked yeah and they knew that if
our voices carried they'd be in trouble
so that's why you know they do things
like you know they take Jakey Rowling's
name off school buildings and stuff like
this it's just it's designed to make
everyone think there's something wrong
with this person there's something badly
wrong am as I say Amy ham three years in
a work tribunal because she put up a
poster saying I love JK rowy so so again
JK rolling created Harry Potter which
kind of you know has had three
generations reading ever since you know
what I mean like at a time when computer
games should be completely obliterating
that activity for young people and she
just saved
like you know saved publishing really um
but all these kids who grew up with her
at the same time were also being
influenced by lunatics on Tumblr and
Reddit who believed a series of
completely incoherent things that you
know actually kind of appropriately
enough are a form of magic you know you
could change sex you know you can escape
the the you can escape your biology you
know and these things are are like
unlike the magic spells in Harry Potter
these are really dangerous things to
tell kids you know so uh so yeah we had
to be destroyed and and conclusively you
know it's a sad story man it's a and you
know I haven't really heard you tell it
quite to that level before and I'm
really sorry that this is the way it's
been it must be very difficult must be
very difficult I will say though from an
outside perspective probably hard for
you to see it like this as you said at
the beginning I actually do think we're
making progress on this issue and uh I
think the more time goes by the more
Vindicated you'll find yourself so hang
in there uh because I do think there's a
lot there's many other things about
which I'm not optimistic at all but on
this one I think certainly in this
country we're actually making progress
and I think that's partly down to you I
know that so many of our female fans in
particular uh as we call them the angry
Bri um my people your your people they
look a bit like me they
do don't laugh it that
much I was going to say like both of you
but you know but the women are annoyed
as well yeah but so many of them are
really
grateful you know that there was a man
actually who who was not some you know I
mean you are a right-wing evil bigot now
but you weren't at the time uh who was
prepared to actually say something so I
know it's really tough right now um but
you know your book has done well it's
getting great reviews from people who
are being objective about it uh and I
really think that this is um you'll look
back on this moment actually with pride
yeah I really do oh I I already do good
I already do yeah yeah I feel like I was
kind of asked a question that people are
asked every so often in history and I
kind of answered it correctly you know
absolutely and there's also something
that I want to say to you which is they
may be able to do all these things to
you they may be able to stop your work
being published for the moment but times
will change but why do you hate trans
people but they will never take away
your talent and I mean this from the
bottom of my heart you are a
generational Talent great oh me I really
appreciate it thank you you inspired me
I'm starting to tear up now to want to
be a comedian and want to be really yeah
[__] hell man father head
guilty yeah there's a lot there's about
12 people who've seen my gigs in total
are very angry at you but you with what
you did with your work it was
Sensational and you don't lose that
Brilliance overnight and through what
you've been through and eventually when
you come out of this because just as
sure as the as night happens Dawn will
come when the dawn will come what you
produce after everything that you've
been through will be so beautiful and
brilliant and I can't wait to see it oh
me that means a lot thank you thank you
really appreciate
it is that but it feels like the ending
though is that the ending sort of has to
be now it sort of feels like after that
anything we ask is going to be weird but
as you know I mean we do ask before we
go to questions from our supporters and
a lot of people have asked questions we
do tend to ask uh our final question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we should be uh and
and you know you might have thoughts on
it you might not no I can I can whistle
something up yeah yeah yeah there you go
oh is that you are you oh I see sorry
this is actually like a conversation
that's actually the question right right
excuse me well [__] the thing that just
jump jumped into my head is Eric
Hoffer's True Believer I think everyone
should be reading it it is a history of
uh mass movements Mass kind of delusions
sometimes um and he wrote it in 1953 he
was like some workingclass guy who
taught himself how to think in various
different uh uh libraries and wrote this
theory of what connected mass movements
everything from national socialism to to
Christianity actually did we talk about
this earlier no no oh good okay um he's
the guy that said every great cause
begins as a movement becomes a business
and eventually degenerates into a racket
yeah did he say that that's interesting
because but well basically he wrote it
in 19 53 and it could have been written
yesterday about this particular movement
it is it is it just it this movement
takes all the boxes of one of these
kinds of moments in history you know it
needs a it's usually uh pretty
comfortable people who who who run these
kinds of movements uh it's there has to
be a sort of nihilism abroad that means
it attracts people who've given up hope
on other things uh it's a very
nihilistic moment at the moment everyone
think the world's going to end in a
couple of months and so on um and I
think all these things uh have come
together in real life the way he wrote
about them and like I was just driving
like I was on the tube train up here and
again I just you can't highlight it
because you just end up highlighting
every the whole book is yellow you know
because everything just strikes you as
um like there's a whole section in it
where he talks about you know how faith
in a Doctrine like gender IDE ology or
like national socialism or like
communism is so uh is so kind of
complete that you can't really have
conversations with people about it
they'll cover up their ears before they
listen because you're questioning the
the doctrine you're questioning the the
true faith that will lead everyone into
a better world and there's actually kind
of you know at at the heart of gender
ideology there is there
is a kind of
a a kind of a reach for something good
which is the idea that if we change our
language then the reality of sexism will
change and it's just not true all all
that happens is that you create kind of
a a a kind of uh super uh um uh what's
the word uh oh God you know when you're
a super privileged form of male right
you know what I mean the sacred class I
sometimes call you know and uh that's
what's happening the opposite to what
they set out to do do it hasn't it
hasn't destroyed sexism it has
created as someone puts it the
patriarchy and stilettos you know and
that's what this is and and uh yeah his
book will I think reading that book will
will everybody reading will just have a
light bul moment you know gr linhan
thanks for coming on follow us over to
locals but before you do make sure you
get yourself a copy of tough crowd and
uh head over to locals where we ask
Graham your
questions
uh with both labor and the conservatives
being so shy does Graham think a third
party might stand a chance and if so
[Music]
who